Speaker 1: It increasingly seems like it is very
dangerous legally to represent the failed former
president Donald Trump. More of Donald Trump's
lawyers may soon need representation themselves.
And as we've said many times before, the real
meaning of MAGA is making attorneys get attorneys.
There's a very interesting article in Salon.
Legal experts say Trump lawyers may need their
own lawyers after DOJ filing. The Justice
Department on Tuesday said in a filing
that Trump and his legal team likely
tried to conceal classified documents
after being hit with a grand jury subpoena.
The 36 page filing came in response to Trump's
dubious request to appoint a special
master to review the seized documents
details the DOJ's evidence of obstruction of
justice. The DOJ filing suggests Trump and his
team may have tried to mislead investigators. When
Trump attorney Christina Bobb signed a document
affirming all classified documents sought by the
archives have been returned. As you now well know,
and as was made clear in this viral photograph
taken on Donald Trump's cheesy casino rugs in his
apartment in Florida. There are plenty of secret
and top secret documents that were there. So,
yes. Making attorneys get attorneys. And
sometimes I start to wonder, don't they know
that the FBI is going to take pictures and that
they're going to film and that it may come out
and you can't just come out and say, we gave all
the documents back. There are no such documents.
The the declassification component, which many of
Trump's lawyers have focused on, is a distraction.
It's not actually relevant in most of the statutes
that are at issue here. And there were lies told
to the FBI by Trump and his attorneys about having
the documents regardless of the classification
status. That's what matters. And as I told you
before, nobody's been charged with anything yet.
But the potential criminal penalties for some
of these things are we're talking about decades
as maximum hypothetical penalties. The classified
documents and the non classified documents are
government documents. Trump did not have the
authority to have them at his house. The DOJ makes
it clear they belong not to an ex-president just
because he took them with them and seemingly doing
self-inflicted damage as well. Just as a reminder,
we looked at this clip on yesterday's show.
One of Trump's attorneys, Olena Haba, putting
herself at the scene of the crime, saying,
I was there. I know exactly what was where.
Speaker 2: Yeah, nowhere. What's happened
is now they've put this picture out so that you
would assume and I am somebody who has been in the
press, loves to talk about this, especially today.
I'm somebody that has been in his office. I've
seen it. This is not the way his office looks.
They give you this appearance that you walk in
and there's these top secret documents just
strewn about A, B, they don't understand.
Something could be marked top secret. Could be
marked classified. The Presidential Records Act,
he would have said this is declassified. It
doesn't get a new marking all the time. He's left
the office. It is a complete public spectacle,
and I'm not really going to stand by it any more.
Speaker 1: He won't stand by it. And yet she may
also soon be a defendant. These people truly are
pathetic in that this is the absolute best that
they can come up with. And so legal jeopardy
is going beyond Trump here. And of course,
there's a question as to if and when anybody
will be charged. And even if they are, will
there be consequences? But Trump's own lawyers
increasingly in legal harms way and also the right
wing, simply can't get on the right talking point